ready look like I'm in pain now you look
buff darling fire hey what's up guys I'm
Jax Jones hi I'm ray and we're playing
just the play bar with blood boiling
[Music]
how'd you open this team wait listen
oh you're G alright we have a nice
orange rocker that consistency going on
here
what's huggy light penetrated my side
yeah every time I smell ease it's just
like oh my nose yeah it's just like
coming
are you actually swimming you it's like
a Chinese dessert and we just opened it
so so why is it so flat already are you
Peter
yes the sparkles all gone did I sniff it
out guess the flavor that costs dusting
that's not on I had my tongue in that
that's unacceptable what you've done to
us there that Bible there's an essay in
a league that's disgusting you know this
has got 42 grams of carbs I'm on a
[ __ ] ketogenic diet Manley that was
[Applause]
no Oh chucka Halloween jury should not
be drank that is some sort of grass
smells like a tsunami wall it's a lot of
addictive no it takes that you shouldn't
be drinking here it just tastes like
dishwater
no I'd like actually need to come and
sit here and try this drink because this
drink sucks I'm not trying to promote
anything that bad to drink that [ __ ]
spinach wheatgrass and don't don't don't
under
why didn't I stay true to grass that's
the first thing I knew is that can I get
half respect for that half a point well
I don't I just trust my god some sick
people probably drink that ya know
that's making me go like that one on my
microphone that I just done how do I be
against our doing no that's black now
this one's lethal I know what that is
already do
thank you no he smells that I'll tell
you now no no I don't to say because I
want to win this one actually I think
I'm gonna win this one I know instantly
let's wrap it this one yeah that's why I
thought it was really you got it already
why do my senses suck trust yourself
go into yourself namaste tires
okay rubber yeah I'm so confused
guess the flavor gherkin it's probably
go fear nothing you're right oh why do I
stop pickles I was closer oh my god it
is pickles boom
Ranch Dressing what the hell is that
what does it make me think of as soon as
this minute my son's ha-ah
so that's really good actually
that's a fire one shouldn't have said
that stealing that alright hit me let's
go guess the flavor so incidence is it
did rot whoa Roger Oh leave it no yeah
actually the author tastes
oh is this the Marquise I actually
wouldn't wish this on my enemy can this
be when it takes it all all right I want
to find time takes it off that's hard
i papa stick it up with Oscar nod that
smells
from in this clause I have no idea what
that is so we add like wrong crayon yeah
but that's to find me eventually right
yeah yeah that's a crayon
that's a crayon that's the crayon guy I
used to eat crayons when I was younger
the flavor Hey crayon if it's a crayon
you give me a high five I'll be pissed
what peanut butter and jelly
no way there's no way
Hey well done Jax you you won fair and
square
taste buds on point that was guess the
flavor a lad Bible oh yeah
you